uh
you've got a5 coming in and
yeah and okay king d5 you just make sure
that your king is coming and then you
you push the pawns i mean you just can't
stop those pawns
we'll stay till the end with this one
and then we quickly switch to the other
boards there's a lot of action
everywhere but just a quick update that
magnus is crushing this yeah magnus is
crushing it yeah liam has turned the
tables he's winning
and the big question is what about anish
i mean vladish hold or or he will do
maybe he will lose actually but yeah for
the moment let's let's just see how
these pawns are queening
so does he go a6 bishop f2 king c6 yeah
that's what i'm expecting he just walks
with ah actually he doesn't even walk he
just pushes b6 and then a7
and if you go bishop a7 you can go king
b7 yeah and that's it
resigns what a game by hands brilliantly
played from start to finish bro put up
the max resistance but hands after that
brilliant play in the opening managed to
convert it